JAMES MOREHEAD: Hello, everyone.
Live here in the room and on
live stream around Google.
Kari Byron is no
stranger to fans
of her multiple reality-based,
science-oriented television
shows, from Discovery
Channel's Mythbusters,
to Netflix's White
Rabbit Project,
to the Travel Channel's
Thrill Factor,
and many other programs.
Kari is also no
stranger to Google.
I had the privilege
of interviewing her
for talks at Google
a couple of years ago
and she co-hosted the
Google Science Fair
with YouTuber, Simone Giertz.
And Kari just joined STEM
toy company, Smart Gurlz,
as their Chief Creative
Officer, as though she hasn't
had done enough amazing things.
So today we're welcoming
Kari back to Google
to talk about her
autobiographical first book,
Crash Test Girl, which
applies the scientific method
to the ups, downs, and
in-betweens of life.
Please welcome Kari to Google.
[APPLAUSE]
KARI BYRON: I like
how you intruded that
as her first book,
as if there's going
to be so many more after this.
JAMES MOREHEAD: Well,
I hope there are
because your book is awesome.
So I had a chance to learn a
new word, galley copy, which
is something I had to Google.
It's a pre-released copy of the
book before it's totally done.
KARI BYRON: I had
to Google it, too.
I didn't know what they
were talking about.
JAMES MOREHEAD: I had
no idea what it means.
I didn't want to ask
the publicist, what's
a galley copy, because I
feel like I should know that.
So you didn't just
write this book.
You created some
amazing sketches,
and we're going to show some
of those in a little bit,
and illustrations to
complement the text.
Walk me through how you
created the opportunity
to write the book, not just
the book itself, but how you
actually made that
opportunity happen
and the process of
writing a first book.
KARI BYRON: I would like it
to be something very grand.
So I was in a bar in Iowa
and I was sitting around
with this random
group of people.
I mean, it was Thomas
Dolby, the guy who wrote,
she blinded me with science.
And if you're an audio
nerd, you probably
know who he is
because he's invented
so many amazing things.
Homer Hickam who wrote Rocket
Boys, which became October Sky,
he was there.
I had Space Gal,
you know, Emily.
JAMES MOREHEAD: Yep.
KARI BYRON: Also, there
was a storm chaser.
Reed Timmer was there
and a former astronaut.
And we just had this
wild group of people
that had done a speaker series.
And we were all hanging
out closer to last call
than I'd like to admit.
And Homer Hickam's like--
we're trading all
these travel stories--
you should write a book.
I was like, no, I
don't want to do that.
I was like, that's what you do.
Writing is really hard.
Every time I do a blog, I
agonize until the last minute.
And it's constantly
being written in my head.
And then it's stressful, and
then I write it, and I'm happy,
but that happiness
is so short-lived
because it's just all at the
end because I got it done,
and it's never perfect enough.
And he's like, no,
just write a book.
You've got all these stories.
You've got so many stories.
Write a book.
And I said, no.
And he basically
double dog dared me.
And I went, fine, fine, fine.
You can let your agent call me.
So his agent called
me and he said,
Homer tells me that you're
going to write a book.
I was like, no.
Nothing counts at that
time in the morning.
I'm not writing a book.
And then I just let it sit.
And I was talking to my
daughter about something
that she had going on
at school, something
that she was afraid of.
And I was looking at her, saying
the words, OK, honey, bravery,
it's not what superheroes have.
It's not having superpowers.
It's being scared to death
and doing it anyways.
And I went, ah.
And I walked out of the
room and went, damn it.
I got to write a book now.
So I called back the agent and
I was like, how do you do this?
What do I do?
And he walked me through this.
You got to write
a book proposal.
So I wrote a horrible
book proposal
that was like 90 pages long.
And I took it to
some publishers.
And I didn't get the reception
that I was hoping for,
so I pulled it back.
And I actually hired
someone to help me
with the book proposal, a
writer that's actually good.
So I was like, how do
I make this something
that people actually
want to buy?
And so she cut it into
pieces and brought it down
to 30 pages instead of
90, which is insane.
And I went back to a
bunch of publishers
and got a whole bunch
of different offers.
So it's really just
the presentation.
I'm like, OK, this is
actually kind of cool.
Writing a book is hard, but the
learning process is amazing.
And it has all of the things
that I've always preached
to my daughter, you know?
Don't be scared.
Make opportunities.
Learn from failure.
So the first going out with the
book was somewhat of a failure.
Learned from it,
called an expert.
Very Mythbustery.
Went back out with it,
got a bunch of offers.
And then all of a
sudden I went, oh, now I
got to do it for real.
So I spent a lot of time
stress eating and drinking wine
during the day in
my living room.
Maybe I should be more of
a role model about that,
but that was just my process.
I took a bunch of
stories from journals.
I had a bunch of stories
written on my computer
already that I had written
down along the way.
I had videos from all
these years at Mythbusters.
I talked to all my friends.
I'm still friends with
a lot of the gang.
So I'd be like, hey,
remember that time?
And then I'd be like, yes.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
I remember that.
And they're like,
are you taking notes?
I'm like, yeah.
So I put together a lot.
I have never realized
how collaborative
a book process is as well.
You've got a designer
that tells you
your pictures are good
or bad or the wrong size.
You've got two,
three editors that
keep coming back at you with
new versions of the book that
take entire chapters
out to say things like,
nobody wants to read
about your childhood.
OK.
That's gone.
More embarrassing stories.
Could you give us more
embarrassing stories?
I'm like, ugh, yes, OK.
So, finally, after--
I think it takes about a year or
so before I had the end result,
and I'd already
spent the advance.
So I put out my version
of mortified for everyone.
There's a lot of
stories that are very--
I make myself very vulnerable.
I definitely talk
about a lot of things
that I don't think
people expected.
It's not a science
book for kids.
It really is my personal memoir.
I always liked memoirs.
And I never liked them
about people who were clean
and had it all figured out.
I like messy people who
learned along the way.
So that's my book.
JAMES MOREHEAD: And
building on that,
I wasn't sure what to expect
because I got this galley copy.
I knew it was a book
and it was about you,
and that's all I knew going in.
And I was really surprised-- you
just touched on this-- that it
was so raw and personal.
It wasn't the pristine
social network
fantasy that represents nobody.
KARI BYRON: Hashtag Instagram.
JAMES MOREHEAD: Yes, it
was kind of a real version
of Kari Byron.
So what was it like
sharing so many aspects
of your private life?
And did you draw
the line anywhere?
Where did you decide
to draw the line?
KARI BYRON: I mean, I put a
lot of private stuff in there.
And it wasn't until after I
turned it into the editors
that I realized that, oh my god.
My dad and mom are
going to read this.
And I told the story
of losing my virginity.
I want to puke right now, but
I already spent the advance,
so it's too late now.
JAMES MOREHEAD: I
think that's going
to be the theme of this talk.
KARI BYRON: Pretty much.
Go.
JAMES MOREHEAD: Yeah.
So you also narrated
the audio book.
You can't do a book
now pretty much
without doing an audio book.
Was that fun, tedious,
painful, all of the above?
KARI BYRON: It was
somewhat excruciating
for a couple of reasons.
One, I've never liked the
sound of my own voice.
I don't think anybody does.
But that's a long period of time
to listen to your own voice.
Also, when I read the
whole thing out loud,
I wanted to change stuff.
Because I had done it so
silently for so long that
the audio book
version is actually
slightly different
than the finished
process of the actual book.
So the more polished
version is in words.
So I prefer you read
it than listen to it.
Because there were a
couple of things I'm like,
that doesn't sound like me.
Why did I write that way?
No, change.
JAMES MOREHEAD: So I'm going to
do a little show and tell now.
It will give the
editing time for--
let's see.
So there's a lot of really
cool artwork in the book.
And I want to have Kari--
KARI BYRON: That's
very kind of you.
They're more like sketches
that mostly were in my journal
that I just traced.
JAMES MOREHEAD: All right.
I can't go through all
of these, but I will just
talk about this.
It Says, love is the
smile that smiles back.
KARI BYRON: Can I give
you a little secret?
JAMES MOREHEAD: Yes.
KARI BYRON: Originally,
that was for something.
I took it out of a journal.
It originally
said, you die alone
so you might as well
be happy with yourself.
But they didn't like
that, so I changed it.
[LAUGHTER]
I changed it to fit the chapter.
JAMES MOREHEAD: Yeah, that's--
KARI BYRON: Inside information.
I've never told that story.
JAMES MOREHEAD: That's
why you have editors.
That's a good choice.
Now, going to the other
end of the spectrum,
this is a weapon that you
could use to attack a zombie.
KARI BYRON: I do
go through and--
this is part of my
zombie apocalypse kit.
I do really have
this in my house.
It has a roll of duct tape.
It has a machete.
Because for some reason over
Christmas a couple of years
ago, two different
people gave me machetes.
I don't know what
that says about me,
but I got two machetes
one Christmas,
so I've got one in my
zombie apocalypse kit.
I mean, everybody
has that, right?
And then a bottle of
unopened champagne.
Because at the
end of the world I
want to be able to savor a
bottle, drink the champagne,
and I have two weapons, a very
sharp bottle for a good eye
socket gouge and a
machete because machete.
JAMES MOREHEAD: So I'm
a zombie fan myself.
Now, I've had many debates
with prior companies
about zombie attacks.
This is not one of
the questions I wrote,
but I want to ask it now.
Where would you rather be
in a zombie apocalypse?
Would you rather
be in a basement?
Would you rather be
in a deserted island?
Would you rather be on a boat?
Or would you rather
be in your apartment?
KARI BYRON: Jamie's workshop.
JAMES MOREHEAD:
Jamie's workshop.
That would be a
good place to be.
All right, I'm going
to choose one more.
Let's see.
Oh, I like this one, all
right, because I think
it's a good theme for the book.
The harder I work,
the luckier I get.
And I think that there's a lot
of threads in the book that
tie back to this concept.
So what does that mean
to you, that statement?
KARI BYRON: Well, I know it's
a Thomas Jefferson quote,
but I saw it at the
back of a tattoo parlor.
And it was just about
this scrappy guy
that just made his
way, even though he
had some physical disabilities.
And I was like, yes, that
guy's successful because he
worked very, very hard.
And for me, I've never
necessarily had it easy.
I mean, yes, I am a
white suburban girl,
so I haven't had it too hard.
But I have always worked very
hard for my opportunities,
from getting my
job at Mythbusters.
I worked for free and busted
my ass to stay in that job.
And I've always
worked very hard.
And it's created opportunities.
The reason I'm
sitting here now is
because I keep pushing
myself as much as I can
to do weird and wild things.
And it's generally
beyond the scope
of what I'm comfortable with.
I'm constantly making
myself uncomfortable to get
to the places I want to be.
JAMES MOREHEAD: Cool.
So I love the
premise of the book.
That the scientific
method can be
applied to life, not just
science and engineering
problems.
And I thought that was a
really cool hook for the book.
So how do you define
the scientific method?
But more importantly, how
did that concept become
the unifying theme of the book?
KARI BYRON: Well,
I needed a good way
to tell the story
that was very cohesive
with a lot of strange,
different pieces of my life.
And very early on
in Mythbusters we
realized that the
perfect narrative
vehicle for busting
a myth and telling
a story in the allotted
amount of time that we had
was to use the
scientific method.
And that was the story
arc for all of our myths.
And the scientific method
is really just a tool
in critical thinking.
And so you can apply that to any
decision that you have to make,
because it's all really about
creating an experiment--
slurring-- and then
analyzing it and finding
the conclusions that are
going to help you learn.
So whether you fail or
if things turn out well,
it's all about going
through that process.
JAMES MOREHEAD: So you devote
an entire chapter to money,
among many other topics.
You weren't born with a silver
spoon to carry you at all.
And people may not assume
that, given your success.
You really hustled
to pay the bills.
You worked multiple jobs, nights
as a sampler for liquor brands,
arbitraging, secondhand
clothing via thrift shops.
What did you learn
from those days
of hustling to pay the bills
that helps you out today?
KARI BYRON: I mean, the hustle
is hard when you're young.
And I really did learn that
there's always a way as long
as you keep looking for it.
I really did enjoy--
San Francisco, I'm sure
a lot of you remember,
used to be just this
real thrifty haven.
And you used to be able to
go out to the rich suburbs,
and you'd look around
for designer shoes
and be like, oh,
those are Ferragamo?
Yes, $2.
Thank you, charity run by nuns.
I'm going to go to San
Francisco and sell these for $20
at the thrift store on Haight.
And I used to make
a huge living--
well, huge.
I paid the rent with that.
But I think that I just
learned that there's always
a hustle somewhere
and you just have
to think outside the box,
which you guys do well here.
I think everybody probably
has the hustle here.
JAMES MOREHEAD: I like
that, having the hustle.
You also touch on love.
And I won't get into
losing virginity stories.
Awkward.
But you also share this
really touching anecdote
about your husband and fellow
artist, Paul, giving you
the gift of 365 love letters,
one for each day of the year.
Whoo, that raises the bar.
Celebrities seem to
struggle with relationships.
What has given your
relationship staying power,
despite celebrity?
And you write about
imperfections along the way.
KARI BYRON: I'm an
accidental celebrity.
I'm not somebody who sought
out this life in any way.
And I live in San
Francisco, you know?
We don't have a big
celebrity culture.
And I met my husband before
all of this nonsense.
And he's always been
a big support to me
and I'm a big support to him.
And I honestly think
that I fell in love
with the person that felt like
a chemical reaction rather
than an analog.
He didn't check the right
boxes, but he just felt right.
So for me it was more about
biology than it was, say--
I think Tinder and all that's
an amazing thing for filtering,
but I think it's the
real human contact that's
going to keep you together.
JAMES MOREHEAD: Yeah.
And that human contact, you meet
a lot of people in your role.
And they know you through
your media persona.
And you write interestingly
about sometimes feeling lonely
when around lots
of people and that
you don't mind being
alone, necessarily.
And you write about
amazing experiences you've
had with complete strangers.
What have you learned
about friendship
when so many people assume
or want to be your friend?
KARI BYRON: Well,
I feel like you
have different places that
you have different people
that you need.
You might have that one
friend that you bicycle with
and that one friend
that you get everything
you need from for a day and you
may not ever see them again.
So when I'm traveling
a lot, I'm not
famous enough for somebody to be
pointing me out on the street.
I can go to a bar, and still
hang out with a stranger.
And sometimes I meet
the most amazing people
just while I'm on
the road and having
one-on-one conversations.
And I never tell them
what I do for a living.
I kind of skirt
around it and I can
have a friendship for a minute.
JAMES MOREHEAD: Cool.
All right, I want to do
a little bit more show
and tell because there's so
many cool things back here.
All right, so this is
where editing comes in.
KARI BYRON: But isn't
it live-streamed?
JAMES MOREHEAD: Oh,
the live stream, they
can see all the unedited.
But--
KARI BYRON: Edit
it in your brain.
JAMES MOREHEAD:
--YouTube is going
to get the edited version.
All right, so tell
me a little bit
about this interesting
piece of art.
So we'll see how that's--
KARI BYRON: So I have grown
a passion for black powder
over the years.
And it's not just the
explosive nature of it.
I always liked the
detritus it left behind.
And I always notice that
after we do explosions,
I would go check out the
mayhem that it left behind.
And there was a beautiful
artisticness to the chaos.
So I will use black
powder in paintings.
I will fence it off in some way.
I always thought
round things always
just look like planets to me.
And I try to control the
chaos as much as possible,
but you can't replicate
it twice the same way.
So I explode black powder
of different grains
and then I paint within
it to try to make
these spacey-like themes.
And interior designers
seem to like them.
I either saw them at art
auctions for charity,
or this one's going into
somebody's home, I believe.
JAMES MOREHEAD: Do you
have challenges at TSA
if you go get on a
flight right after you've
done black powder art work?
KARI BYRON: I'll tell you what.
I have gone straight from
the bomb range through TSA
several times with
it just all over me,
exploded ordinance, and
didn't get tagged at all.
But you make fun of the
TSA once on social media,
and Tory and I are completely
separate parts of the lines,
and both of us got
the serious pat down.
Apparently they found
explosives on my phone.
I mean, it's been years.
I think I'm on a watch list now.
JAMES MOREHEAD: All right.
So, now, you actually talked
about some of these last time.
And you graciously
agreed to bring--
I'll hold this up for the--
so describe what
this little fella is
and where it came to be.
KARI BYRON: So there's
two kinds of parenting.
There's the good
parenting and then
there's the creative parenting.
I'm the kind of mom that,
when my kid isn't brushing
her teeth, I'll show her
pictures of meth teeth
and be like, eh, you
want to be like this?
Because this will happen to you.
She hasn't figured it out yet.
She hasn't Googled.
So these little characters are
a series of creative parenting
that I touch on in the book
where my child and I work
through her disgusting habits--
and all children have so many
that there's a lot of material
there--
by creating these
monsters that are supposed
to be mommy's manners monsters.
These are lessons.
So this guy is the
nail biting monster.
It's attracted to the smell
of freshly chewed nail beds.
And when you fall
asleep at night,
if you'd chewed your nails, it
will come in and finish them
off.
These are the booger monsters,
which they live in your nose.
And if you go up
there, pick your nose,
and you steal
their food, they're
going to get hungry and go into
the next available hole, which
might be your ear.
And it will go into your
brain, and it will eat that,
and then you won't
learn to read.
JAMES MOREHEAD: Just one more.
So this is a pretty macabre.
And think you put this
out on in social media,
but describe what
this is all about.
KARI BYRON: I just do do a lot
of tiny, little sculptures.
I lived in San Francisco
and everything has
to be tiny and compact there.
So I work very often in this
size or much, much smaller.
But this one was
somewhere around the time
of contract
negotiations, I believe,
where I was being told to
be part of the machine.
So I do a lot of sculptures
that just are how I work out
my feelings at night.
It's better in a little studio
than, say, getting very angry
and putting out blogs.
I make them personal.
JAMES MOREHEAD: So, yes.
By doing that angry email that
you send in a few seconds,
a little hard to do the
angry sculpture because you
have a little more time
to reflect, and refine,
and decide.
KARI BYRON: I make
better decisions that way
than Facebooking my angst.
JAMES MOREHEAD: So
you write in your book
about having an
artsy, punk aesthetic,
about redefining
yourself as a rebel.
How important is style?
And how important is that for
young people to think about?
KARI BYRON: It was
really important to me
when I was young.
I mean, when I
started Mythbusters,
I had so many piercings that it
all fell away the older I got.
But I think that
it's important to be
respectful for the right
places that you're going to.
You're definitely not going
to wear your boobie shirt
at grandma's.
But I think that it definitely
is something when you're young.
It's a really
interesting process
of how you're trying
to define yourself
and the people that
you are around.
JAMES MOREHEAD: Cool.
So there's a couple of
areas of the book that
get pretty serious.
And I want to touch
on a couple of those
because I think it's
viable for other people
going through similar things.
You're right about that you
like the control of sobriety.
And that said, you write
openly about alcohol,
both as a liquor
brand ambassador
and going through what you
call a saturated period.
What was your trigger to change
your relationship with alcohol?
KARI BYRON: I mean, mostly it
was having a job that I really
cared about.
You can't really show
up with a hangover
when you work with power tools.
Though it's an Australian
production company,
we had a very healthy
relationship with the end
of the day, and alcoholic.
It slowly became more
interesting to me to not overdo
it.
I have depression and so
I found that in my youth
I self-medicated a
lot with alcohol.
And it's something that
I see a lot of kids
do because they
don't understand.
They're depressed.
They think that they just
have problems with the world
that they're in.
And I think a lot of kids start
drinking very young and very
heavily to fix that.
And so I wanted to
put it out there
that that's what I was doing
and the mistakes that I made
so that maybe you
figure out that you're
going through
hormonal depressions
rather than ending up an
alcoholic because you're
trying to fix something that
isn't actually a problem that's
external.
It's internal.
JAMES MOREHEAD: I mean, that's
a perfect lead into an area
that I thought was the
most powerful in the book,
was where you talk
openly about wrestling
with depression for many years.
And it is not something
people would probably
assume from this media persona
that evidently follows you
around.
So how did you become
aware that you had
something called depression?
KARI BYRON: I
mean, it really was
when I started on Mythbusters.
And I had this dream job.
And I had a husband--
well, he was my
boyfriend at the time--
but I had this man that
I was in love with.
I had a great apartment.
I had everything, and
there was nothing wrong,
and I couldn't assign
blame to anything.
And I was like, oh my god.
This feels chemical.
This is something
that I can't control.
And so that's when I started
to address it in that way.
And that's how I figured
out how to deal with it.
But the reason that
I put it in the book
is because I had met a woman
on the road, a young woman.
She was in college and she
was saying, I get depression.
And how do you make
it through when
you're trying to achieve these
goals but you're weighed down?
And I started to tell
her, I had the same thing.
And I could see it in her eyes
that it was almost like relief
to her that this person that
she saw on TV, that she thought
was always happy and
always had it together,
had the same thing that she had.
And it touched her.
And she told me later.
She's like, that
really helped me.
And I thought, OK, well,
if I can do that, I mean,
I might as well
put it in the book.
What have I got to lose?
I can help somebody
possibly with it.
JAMES MOREHEAD: And
you tried everything.
You tried all kinds of
different strategies,
medicinal strategies,
toughing it
out strategies,
everything in between.
And different things will
work for different people.
What has helped you
manage depression,
even though it's
probably always going
to be with you for
the rest of your life?
KARI BYRON: Scientific method.
I did a lot of experimenting.
And, I mean, for me
personally, being
somebody who likes
the dark, arty side,
medicating didn't work for me.
I found the side
effects horrendous.
I found it very difficult.
And I tried and tried
in different ways.
And I honestly find I
go completely sober.
I exercise like a crazy
person for the endorphins.
I eat super-duper healthy.
And I know that
it's going to pass,
which is, now that
I know what it is,
I know it's going to go away.
It's made it a lot easier.
I also put myself in social
situations with other people.
I find that it
actually really helps
to not lock myself
away and hide it.
JAMES MOREHEAD: Well, thanks
for sharing that so openly
in the book.
Because there's other
people that will probably
never would have assumed that
and it will make a difference.
So just a couple
more questions before
I open it up to the Dory
and the folks in the room.
KARI BYRON: But you
actually read the book.
A lot of people that interview
me, they just ask Mythbuster
questions the whole time.
JAMES MOREHEAD: Yeah, no.
I actually read the book.
I read the book on a flight
to Nashville, actually.
And it is a perfect four-hour
round trip length flight book.
KARI BYRON: Oh, fantastic.
Dear airport bookstores,
James Morehead says--
JAMES MOREHEAD: Exactly.
Exactly.
KARI BYRON: Yes.
JAMES MOREHEAD: So Mythbusters
was an amazing contribution
to reality television.
And it was really sad when the
show inevitably came to an end.
You dedicated an entire
chapter to setbacks, including
how Mythbusters ended.
What have you learned
from those setbacks
that helped you going forward?
KARI BYRON: I mean, I thought
that the world was ending
for a minute when I left
Mythbusters because that
had been my first--
it was just such a huge job.
It was over a decade long.
And it was everything I knew.
And it was everything that I'd
put all my passion and heart
into for so long that I
was suddenly completely
unqualified to do anything
else, because nobody
needs you to drive a
forklift and blow things up
in regular jobs.
I was terrified.
I went to the mall.
I bought a pair
of Theory slacks.
I was about to get my
LinkedIn all ready.
I'm just like, OK.
I don't know if this is--
there's just no
boxes for what I do.
I have no idea.
So being able to gather
myself from that and go, OK.
What do I like to do?
What do I want to do?
I kind of like this TV thing.
Maybe I can do this TV thing.
I'm going to keep going.
So I actually just started
going out and pitching shows
on my own, and letting people
know that I'm still here,
and I'm ready to
work on other things.
And other shows
started showing up.
They're like, oh,
Mythbusters is over?
Come over here.
And Travel Channel's
like, we would love you.
Come do science on
roller coasters.
And it was a good lesson
that life continues beyond,
even when the
wonderful things end.
So that's why I've
continued on with TV,
and I'm moving into new
fun fields myself now.
JAMES MOREHEAD: Yes, so
that's a perfect lead
in to my last question,
because it's your next gig.
You've recently joined a
cool startup, Smart Gurlz.
Is there--
KARI BYRON: Oh, I have one.
I do have one.
JAMES MOREHEAD: Yes, you
got to do show and tell.
This is our last show and tell.
OK, so I'm looking
forward to understanding
more about the cool
startup, Smart Gurlz,
that you recently joined as
their Chief Creative Officer
that's creating self-balancing,
programmable robots,
targeting girls
with action dolls.
What will your role
be and how did you
get connected to
this opportunity?
And you should
definitely show this.
It's really cool.
KARI BYRON: Let's see.
Can I show it on the floor?
Should I try to show it up here?
JAMES MOREHEAD: Let's see.
I think probably up here.
KARI BYRON: All right, move
these little guys over.
JAMES MOREHEAD:
Let's move these.
Yeah.
KARI BYRON: So I
did not invent this.
JAMES MOREHEAD: So it's
like a little Segway?
KARI BYRON: I don't
want her to drop off.
Give her some room.
JAMES MOREHEAD: Yeah.
KARI BYRON: Hold on.
OK, because she's trying
to learn to self-balance.
JAMES MOREHEAD: Almost, yeah.
KARI BYRON: Well, if
she jumps off the edge,
it'll be more like me.
JAMES MOREHEAD: Well, that
will be a Mythbusters moment,
so there you go.
KARI BYRON: She's got
her little Segway.
She does that to self-balance.
So that's her.
I thought to myself, what
do I want to do besides TV?
Because I like TV, but
it's feast or famine.
Sooner or later I want
to do something new.
And I always wanted to do toys.
And that's next
on my bucket list,
is I want to work in toys.
So I just started getting on the
Google and researching places
that did it, and how they
did it, and what they--
I talked to everybody I
knew about connections.
And just a friend had
talked to a guy who
was involved in this company.
I cold-called him and
asked him out to coffee
to pick his brain.
And by the end, he's like, wow,
this is kind of your brand.
I mean, this is a
STEM for girls brand.
So this is a doll on
a self-balancing robot
that is completely codable.
And it teaches block
coding to girls
using their tablet
or their phone
so that the doll can
move through challenges.
It can dance.
Music comes out of it.
But it speaks to
the way girls play,
which is they do a
lot more storytelling.
And I feel like, at one point,
the whole revolution was, OK,
we've got to teach girls STEM,
so don't make anything pink.
Because that's too girly and
STEM doesn't have to be girly.
And I feel like
now the revolution
against the revolution is,
or the girls like pink,
let's also teach them
coding and computer science.
Let's make toys for everyone.
And this is supposed to
reach girls at the age
that they stop being interested
in coding and computer science
because all the toys start
getting very masculine.
They're robots,
and they're cars,
and they're things that destroy,
whereas my daughter who's
in love with Minecraft
and loves coding
is now one of only two girls in
her entire after school program
because every year they
dropped off, they dropped off,
they dropped off.
Because she likes to code in
ways that creates stories.
And she makes these
big castles that all
have a reason for everything.
And then the boys in the
class go in and blow it up.
So they're both really good.
It's just I think
that sometimes we
need to make it easier for girls
to continue on in this field.
So this is just the launch toy.
This is the one that-- it
was seen on Shark Tank,
and that's where
they got their start.
JAMES MOREHEAD: Oh, cool.
KARI BYRON: And they won
out of 40,000 companies.
And they've got such a
great hustle going on
that I met the founder
and I was just like, yeah,
I would like to
join with you guys.
I'm going to help them in their
next round of seed funding
so that we can actually
start making more.
And then I've got a
bunch of new coding toys
that will probably be
coming out by Christmas.
JAMES MOREHEAD: Awesome.
That is so cool.
So we are now going to shift
to audience and Dory questions.
But before I do, I have
two copies of the book.
I learned, as I
mentioned before, this
is the galley copy, the
one that I actually read
with all the post-it notes.
KARI BYRON: You didn't
tell them what that means.
JAMES MOREHEAD:
Galley copy, well, I
didn't know what it
meant, so I Googled it.
So galley copy is
a pre-released copy
of the book, not
entirely finished.
I someday will read
the released copy
to see what the differences are.
How significant are
the differences?
KARI BYRON: They're
not significant,
but to me they were.
They were important
changes to me.
They're very small.
JAMES MOREHEAD: So
the book is fantastic.
I strongly recommend you pop
out your smartphone right now
and order up a copy.
And I see there are copies
already in the audience.
It just came out.
KARI BYRON: Yay, thank you.
JAMES MOREHEAD: And it's
just a really good read.
It's very unexpected.
So with that, we will
get my assistant,
who's an engineer with our
team, to get the microphone.
All right.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming in.
The book, I haven't
quite finished it yet,
but it's great.
It's so easy and interesting.
I really appreciated, and you
touched on it a little bit
already, that you were
very honest about dealing
with depression and how
it was hard on Paul, also.
I'm wondering if you have
any advice for people
who find themselves in Paul's
place, who want to help,
but don't know how to do so.
KARI BYRON: It's
really tough when
you're married to somebody
who does have depression.
And I think that
in any family it's
very difficult because you
take it very personally.
When that person
is sad or angry,
it's always going to
feel like it's at you.
I think that the
most important thing
is to remember it's not you.
And you also have to just
take care of yourself.
The partner of someone
who's depressed
has to really understand
that it's not something
that they caused, and just be
as understanding as possible.
But I think it's also
the depressed person
has to, as well, be
very understanding
that that situation is something
that is going to happen
and that you have to take
extra care of each other.
JAMES MOREHEAD: Great question.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JAMES MOREHEAD: All right, let's
take another one from the room.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So sort of
a two-part question.
We become who we are
from our experiences.
So would you say that
everything you've gone through
in your life has been
necessary, or would present-day
you go back in time and
try to change something
that you did in the past?
KARI BYRON: That is
something somebody asked me,
and I put some of
it in the book.
Present-day me would go
back and invest in Google.
I would have stocks
in all of that.
That would be amazing.
But, yeah, I mean,
it definitely took
a lot of tripping and falling.
And I don't think that
I would be here or be
as happy as I am
with my life now
if I hadn't had all of these
scary, awful experiences
or wonderful experiences.
So I wouldn't say I
don't regret anything.
I just say I've
definitely learned a lot.
JAMES MOREHEAD:
So from the Dory,
somewhere out on live stream.
You probably get this
question quite a bit.
What's the myth you most
want to have revisited
because you think
it has to be true
but was busted on the show?
KARI BYRON: That has to be true?
JAMES MOREHEAD: Has to be true.
It was busted on the
show, but it just
didn't feel like it
should have been busted.
KARI BYRON: I don't know.
I kind of agreed with
most of our results,
except for fireworks man.
Fireworks man, we launched
a guy with fireworks.
And I feel like the producers
wanted it to not be real,
so they came up with a different
conclusion that I came up with.
But in the end, it was the
group ruled against me.
So I wouldn't want to actually
retest that one because it
was kind of ridiculous.
In fact, most of them, I'm
pretty satisfied with how
they came out in the end.
JAMES MOREHEAD: Yeah.
I think you made a big
difference around the cell
phone at the gas station.
KARI BYRON: Yes.
JAMES MOREHEAD: I love that.
I thought that had a
very positive impact
on gas stations.
They used to put a sticker,
no cell phone near the gas,
even though it's totally absurd.
KARI BYRON: I would like
people to stop firing bullets
into the air when they're
celebrating because we
know that they come down.
That was another
one that I thought
was very good, that we actually
had some statistical research
happen from the show.
Also, the one that I really,
really like people to believe
is the airport
lines when you are
boarding a plane,
where it doesn't
matter the zones you are.
If everybody just boards
and does it efficiently,
the most efficient
people will generally
get to the front of the line and
they'll do everything quickly.
And then the slacker people,
which somehow always end
up in first class, just like,
oh, let me put my dog here,
they're always in the front.
And I think it would be
so much faster if we just
let nature take its course.
JAMES MOREHEAD: Or you
know what we should do?
KARI BYRON: I feel
very strongly.
I fly a lot.
JAMES MOREHEAD: Every time
you fly, you should be timed,
and then your next flight
is adjusted based on how
you performed the last time.
KARI BYRON: Yes.
JAMES MOREHEAD: And then
that will sort it all out
all the time.
And the people that
don't mind, they
don't mind taking a long
time, they'll be at the end
and they don't care.
KARI BYRON: Yeah, yeah.
JAMES MOREHEAD: So we got
another from the audience.
Here we go.
AUDIENCE: Oh, hi.
Hi.
So I'll admit I haven't
read the book yet,
but it seems you've done a
lot of traveling in your time.
And I was wondering what
the biggest piece of advice
you have is for
someone who will be
spending some time in
an unfamiliar place.
KARI BYRON: It depends
in different countries.
If you're in Egypt,
you didn't drop
anything, no matter how
many people say, hey,
you dropped something.
Don't stop and turn around.
You didn't drop anything.
I would say it would be
my best piece of advice.
But, no, I think
sometimes you've
got to not look at
the travel blogs
and just let it go and explore.
Because I think that's the most
interesting part of traveling,
is just stumbling into things.
It's great to have an idea
of where you're going,
but I generally--
even in the United
States, we do a lot
of filming in places like
Philadelphia, for example.
I knew that I had six hours
before I had to be anywhere,
so I looked for the best vegan
cheesesteak I could find.
And it was miles away.
I'm like, OK, I
want to walk there,
no matter what neighborhood
I have to walk through.
And along the way, I
found so many cool things,
like art galleries, and weirdo
people, and oddities shops.
And the Mutter Museum
was on the way, which
is the medical oddities museum.
So I found so much
craziness along the way
just to get to the
vegan cheesesteak.
And it was the journey,
not the reward.
It was delicious, by the way.
So I had this whole
entire adventure
because, instead of, OK, I can
sit in this hotel room for six
hours, I made some sort
of arbitrary destination
and just let my feet
take me into the weird.
JAMES MOREHEAD: So we'll
take one more from the Dory
and one more from the audience.
So I'm sure you get
asked this a lot, too.
If you had a chance to do
Mythbusters again, would you?
Or is that part of your
life, had wonderful bookends
and that's that?
KARI BYRON: I don't know.
Because Mythbusters can't
be Mythbusters again.
Because I've learned a
bunch from Mythbusters.
And the whole amazing
thing of the journey
is that I had no
idea what I was doing
at all from the beginning.
Everybody thought Mythbusters
was a science show.
It wasn't a science show.
None of us have a
science background.
We all were just experiencing it
together and learning together.
And I almost feel
like, at this point,
I don't know if I would have the
same giant reactions to things
because I know when stuff's
going to blow up now.
So I'm not sure if
I could do it again.
JAMES MOREHEAD: Cool, so who
wants to be our last question?
Hand raise, or down here.
No pressure.
You're the last question.
AUDIENCE: I don't mean to
fixate on Mythbusters, but--
KARI BYRON: It's OK.
That's the whole
reason that I'm here.
AUDIENCE: Jamie
and Adam have been
pretty open about the
chemistry or lack thereof.
At Google, we talk a
lot about cultural fit
when we talk about a candidate.
But it sort of seems that
their lack of chemistry
has actually produced
something really great that
lasted for as long as it did.
Do you think it's
actually more important
for a successful project
to have good team chemistry
or to have that clash
of personalities
that the two, I
guess, hosts had?
KARI BYRON: Well, you can
have a clash of personality,
but you still have to have
a respect for each other
and what you bring to the table.
When that's gone, it's over.
My team, with Tory,
and Grant, and I,
we had amazing chemistry.
And so the three of us had the
same fun Mythbustery results
than Jamie and Adam
that had the clash.
But I think that
the common thread
is that we all respected
each other's skill set
and what we brought to the table
and appreciated the diversity.
Because I really do think
that diversity is the best
way to solve any problem.
JAMES MOREHEAD: Cool.
KARI BYRON: And we
still all hang out.
I still torture
Tory all the time.
We still prank each other a lot.
That's kind of my dream,
is to have a prank show.
JAMES MOREHEAD: What's
your favorite prank,
if you could choose just one?
You talk about some of this
in the book, the pranks.
And that--
KARI BYRON: I mean,
on Mythbusters, we
did a lot of different pranks.
But Tory and I, at one point,
trying to create a prank show--
it didn't get bought,
but we actually
perpetrated an amazing
prank on some unknowing
people that thought they
were on a reality show.
We brought them in to watch
the process of cryogenics
and told them that
it was all real,
and then had the cryogenically
frozen people turn into zombies
and attack them.
And it was hilarious.
And I'm dying to put it on
to the YouTube at some point
secretly.
Maybe somebody will leak it.
JAMES MOREHEAD: Yeah, if YouTube
and [INAUDIBLE] watch it.
Cool.
KARI BYRON: But that was the
funnest I ever perpetrated
myself on a grand scheme.
But other than that,
Tory's made me vomit a lot
by drinking things
that I thought
were bodily fluids that
actually he switched it
with some special effects.
All of the sudden he's drinking
an entire beaker of old saliva
and I'm throwing
up on the floor,
but it turns out it was
just tea and he's a jerk.
JAMES MOREHEAD:
Well, with that, I
think it's appropriate that
we end with a Tory story.
KARI BYRON: OK, what you got?
JAMES MOREHEAD: No, [INAUDIBLE].
KARI BYRON: Darn.
JAMES MOREHEAD: So
I want to thank you
for coming back to
Google a second time,
trekking down from the city.
And everyone, Crash Test
Girl, it's a fantastic book.
You're going to learn
something from it.
It's very personal.
It's emotional.
It's not what you'd expect.
And I highly recommend it.
And I actually read the book.
So hopefully your other
book tour interviews,
you get a mix of people
who read the book.
So I want to thank you again
for coming back to Google.
It's been a pleasure
having you here.
KARI BYRON: Well,
thanks for inviting me.
I love it here.
[APPLAUSE]